A close encounter with a man-eating giant.
A sorceress who turns men into pigs.
A long-lost king taking back his throne.
On their own, any of these make great stories,...
...but each is just one episode in the "Odyssey,"...
...a 12,000-line poem spanning years of ancient Greek history,...
...myth, and legend.
Tradition identifies its author as a blind man named Homer...
...but no one definitively knows whether he was real or legendary.
The earliest mentions of him occur centuries after his era.
And the poems attributed to him seem to have been changed...
...and rearranged many times by multiple authors...
...before finally being written down in their current form.
In fact, the word rhapsode means stitching together,...
...as these poets combined existing stories, jokes, myths,...
...and songs into a single narrative.